how's it goin jacksepticeye fans it's me
thank you for having me
we are Eastern European boys apparently
so I was slapped squatting on ground we
like disco vodka and Adidas and but my
favorite is the jacksepticeye and
PewDiePie collab with you some of the
best content ever on YouTube platform
I'm sorry you want me to lick off this
where I thought for our epic collab
we're gonna look at all the other epic
collapse through the years through the
years
septic pie through the you cystic pipe
if you didn't know this I gave this guy
shoutout I don't have you heard about
this actually I want to give my second
shout out jack sexy guy
these are youth - oh gaming videos for
six years seven years almost of now you
stop the flow alright sorry too much
code I mean gee Phil we've been drinking
gee feel hi ray our first collab 2014 14
wait June 2014 it's almost been five
years since the first time we you did
the shout out before that though I was
like I don't know if in this game yes I
liked was like thank you so much beauty
about this is so amazing yeah and then
no reply it didn't like it tweet me back
and then a couple of a while later we
got into this collab together and you're
like oh this guy it's exactly I mean I
didn't see your tweet or whatever no the
thing is like a shout out so many people
yeah and then like 12 yeah and I just
forgot about you
remember oh it's the loud Irish guy Wow
we should play game now
oh I don't have here powers Wow I
remember this you know what this means
we cross streams bro even cross streams
wow I like this is back then you put the
microphone hey guys welcome to
collaboration hello every video quality
sucks these days is because you went
from having audio quality for like four
years and then you morph into [ __ ] video
quality well not now because using
myself
yeah that's my right this is June 25th
and then after that collab after collab
after all it was just a non-stop steam
training on
I don't think we climbed after that I
could not find anything else from 2014
and this is June oh you left a little
comment and I dumped you thumb up your
own company that's so cringy four years
ago well to be fair like a lot of times
if you don't we won't even be shown up
anyway I think I was the star of the
session the enthusiasm was just too much
you didn't even pin it go back and pin
it right now pin back back go back and
pay my comment wait there's so many
times when I find videos that I've
watched years ago and I'm like I
remember this video when I go to an le
left a really cringey comment and I just
delete the comment thing because it's
too bad I love it and I pin it oh my god
go to this video now my comment there's
at the top add that to my notice so then
we played GTA 5 this is a time where
everyone was playing video games
together yeah it was so easy to call a
because the G mod GTA this is before GTA
role-playing was a thing now yeah I know
everyone's obsessed with GTA again
fifteen five minute video truly was a
Wild West all you needed was a good soul
this is seven million views that's
pretty crazy
we also collide what else oh you were
against on the broken podcast you were
number four pre Green Jack that's what I
do whenever I get out of these calls you
guys like go and call some other people
like oh my god I just twitch now poor
jack so ignored I think I think people
thought you guys were in the same room
ah and I was like on a call or something
you think so no greener greener mean the
boys
me and the boys that was when Alexa had
just come out yeah you added a black
dildo to it yeah I did
no horse dildo see clearly I'm a great
friend and you remember all my jokes
oh I click vated you in the in the yeah
was the first time I came to Brighton my
first visit I'm sorry action figure V
thank you
yeah this is when you got like the Ruby
play button and everything this is
before 50 million
I like how I was like okay jack is
coming down I'll vlog that will be good
video that was because I was gonna come
in and disrupt your whole schedule I was
like I need to vlog so I actually get
videos done today
I was I was interrupting your way
YouTube very grind man you Matt's here
brought me around to the antique step
there oh really
you brought me yes you always do
Oh classic the jacksepticeye row I
pointed out the look of my one because I
pointed out that it has the same amount
of use all my holy [ __ ] dude
yours is funny no yours hey
jacksepticeye I bet you think we're bros
just cuz we hang out I bet you think
we're straight-up
home dogs just cuz we hugged once well
guess what I hate my dog and I hate you
too
prepare to gets a nose bag do you want
some tissues
why Braun hey Jack
when I first saw you I gag your facial
hair makes you look like a member of
Isis looks like a vagina waxing wait
like the PewDiePie roles I watched it
all just because we hang out I bet you
think we're straight-up home dog oh my
good ones cuz yours get first I hate my
dog and I hate you too this is the
jacksepticeye so I think people were
reacting can't be late there you see it
we're not realizing that we should there
be make sure you do this oh that's it
that's it oh it's all the current
youtubes 235 more like pew I wish you
died right I have a prepubescent figured
well maybe I just don't want to grow one
as long as yours that makes me look like
a homeless person in the future
oh I trying to Rose me right Brad gave
me some I know he did Swedish boy you
sure look like a potato you say this is
my family I eat this for breakfast yeah
I had to go out and buy potatoes for
this open there we go so potatoes right
now but I want to make the video
subscribers where's all the views bro
that's real that hurts us all hey
Phoenix what are you gonna start
uploading in 1080p or 60 so that was my
one cuz that that was my roast
it's so stupid like who gives a [ __ ]
well clearly do you know what to hit on
yeah your views and your upload I would
show you what you really look like
except it's against Terms of Service to
pull down my pants to show my ass to the
camera on YouTube where you trying so
hard to be a watered-down filthy Frank
yeah that was that was that could deep
you think so
I like how as well I was like you think
I cop you it's like I'll copy each other
alright everyone copies each other on
YouTube do you remember this video this
is the fire do you like having cream on
your face really I thought you hated
what it didn't work
come on no I didn't we found out
afterwards that the guy was lying for a
lot of them really every youtuber thinks
for the best yeah that's every YouTube
did you dye your hair because you were
jealous of me in America I don't know
what to answer did you dye your hair cuz
you're jealous of me and mark no just my
hair but not wanted a piece you want to
think I'm covering up your do you think
I look like you no sorry
I would just full-on [ __ ] mode I would
never react like that that was so
uncomfortable what being like trap like
that would cream all over your face I
could not breathe half the time
oh yeah is the other yeah yeah and here
we are today no we're 2017 and then we
just stop collaborating 2018 mmm-hmm
what happens cuz we had falling out we
have a big fallout big backstab and big
no friend no more
you went to LA I did I went to LA for
three months and I went on tour I was
barely in bright-yellow all of last
year's this is one welcome back to
whiskey me drinking whiskey I'm John
here today with me I'm really good at
interest hello and welcome back to
whiskey me drinking whiskey it's like
you know what to say but your brain just
can't keep up with it we gotten so much
like people kept saying we were idiots
in this episode because it was like aged
14 years as it gets 14 years old oh the
proof not what it means and then it went
full circle and then everybody all the
whiskey people were like well
technically it's the same yeah and then
people call them ours God um so weird
Thank You whiskey aficionados well that
was all our collaborations throughout
the history
please can this one get 25 maybe great
yes please and more views more subs as
always use code PewDiePie to get 10% off
chief
[Music]
but you never played super simulator you
know it's fun right I'm not supposed to
give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]